Nói Mú mũ tăng bán năm 2018, vụ một thải quân phối hợp với các địa phương tiếp nhận công dân
nhé bũ năm 2018, lấy ra những quân đã sĩ giá trang chọng, nghen gọi đúng
quy định bảo đam an toàn. Nói Mú 2018, vụ một thải quân tiếp nhận hơn
một nghìn chiến sĩ mới từ thị phó hải phòng và các tình còn nỉ.
Hương een, miệng, tình hoa, về gọi lượng tại lưỡa đoàn một bốn mấy và từ đoàn
một năm tám, vụ một thải quân. Hoàn thành một trong phần trong chiến tiếp cấp dân dọc.
Để bảo đam chất lượng tuyên quân, chỉ viết các đường bị đá trụ động phối hợp chặt chẽ với cấp í,
chính quyền địa phương trình hai đe đủ các khâu, các mức trong khi chính tiền trọn công dân như bố thật đủ quy định,
tức hiện công thải, miệng bà đúng lột bảo đam an toàn tự đối. Nếu đó, chất lượng thân như bố năm 2018,
có su hải tốt, chính độ phân hỏa phù hợp, sớ sản bố phòng của chiến quân uống.
Tại liên giá giá nhìn cơn ở các địa phương, thu trường bộ tâu định phòng đã chế tiếp và tớ,
lộn viên càng giản phát triển sĩ mọi phát viên trên tốt quay gương cách mạo tinh thần xuống kích của tuy trên.
Tí cơ khọt tập, dàng lựa cho thành nghiệp kỳ lợt, xây dựa bản lĩnh chính chi vấn vang,
phẩm chất đạo đức trong sáng, sớ sản hiện bố an thành tốt mọi nhé vụ được dạo.
Các đơn vị mọi chuyện trên sĩ mọi đã trụ động phối hợp với đương vị kích giết trên địa bàn và hội phụ nước phòng chính chi vụ một tốt chức trả đó.
Tạo ra chức mình chức anh đương liệp, tạo không khi phân khởi, ở mắt, tiếp theo đồng độc để chiến sĩ mọi ít tâm công tác,
quyết tâm hàn thành tốt nghiệp vụ mây tự nhiên hại đồng hiệp vụ.